bubbles are almost like us it sounds
funny but it's true we need the right
ingredients to create a long-lasting
bubble a healthy bubble one with colors
like us we need good food we need water
we need the right environment for our
skin if the air is too dry our skin gets
dry if it's humidity then our body is
better because we're based mostly off
water bubbles are the same thing
few people spend as much time thinking
about making and manipulating bubbles as
melody Aang
when I'm looking at the top of the
bubble I can see the colors that are
disappearing and it's turning into a
yellow into a grey until it turns into
nothing and also little tiny holes on
the top of the bubble then I know that
that's when it's going to pop she says
bubbles have a universal appeal you know
it puts us back in the moment it's
something that takes you back to your
childhood bubbles were melody Yang's
childhood her family has been putting on
a spectacular soapy show for decades and
her father brought the kids into the act
early on I mean my brother would walk on
stage and he'd put us in a bubble and
then he would slowly teach me my brother
routine now melody performs as part of
the family's gazillion bubbles show
blowing incredible bubbles that swirl
form cubes erupt like volcanoes and
blast off with a stream of smoke they've
even set numerous world records for you
guessed it bubbles they use special
wands and tubes and a secret bubble
formula honestly I don't know the
ingredient my dad knows it different
mixtures are used for different tricks
and taking their show on the road means
adjusting the solution to the
environment being dry and hot that makes
the bubbles evaporate a lot faster and
we have to test out many things we have
to test out the air how humidified it is
in a place that's very elevated high the
air is very thin so we have to make the
bubbles a little bit more stronger we
had to test out if there was any dust
in the area if we were in an old theater
even the water matters we have to use
the water that has the right pH balance
tap water can be very difficult for the
bubbles because of all the chemicals in
it and then there are the years of
experience needed to perfect technique
if I'm like not calm and I'm making a
trick then it just doesn't work out you
know so I really it it becomes a mental
thing so say I have to calm myself down
and I was like I can do this it will
work she blows bubbles within bubbles
and is able to reach inside without
popping them my hands have to be wet if
they're dry the bubble will pop these
aren't just bubbles they're temporary
sculptures that are as much science as
they are skilled melody showed us some
of her favorite tricks starting with the
cube bubble I'm gonna create my first
bubble after that I'm gonna create a
second bubble attached to it the same
size
and then you see the bubbles are
attached it creates a wall a straight
line I'm going to make four more bubbles
around it and this is going to help us
create the cube
all right now using my smoke tube I'm
going to put a cube in the center and
there's our square bubble next the
bubble carousel or spinning bubble an
audience favorite first I'm going to
make a larger bubble next I'm going to
make a bubble attached to it the same
size there we go now I'm going to make a
bunch of tiny bubbles around that
attachment and each of those little
bubbles attaches itself to the bigger
ones with the soap solution acting as a
kind of glue and that forms what she
calls the carousel a sort of bubble belt
line around the center of the two larger
bubbles and then I'm going to make a
bubble in the center
and for the last part she blows a thin
stream of air and those bubbles start to
spin the trick to use just enough air to
push the bubbles but not enough to push
them off the carousel there's a carousel
finally she showed us one of her
personal favorites the planet bubble
which creates a miniature solar system
of orbiting bubbles within bubbles I'm
gonna clear the tube the larger tube and
I'm gonna fill it up with smoke then I'm
going to dip it into the solution to
block the smoke from coming out next I'm
going to make a larger bubble grab it
with my wand and I'm going to place the
tube in the centre and take that out
alright next I'm going to use a smaller
tube to extract the smoke from inside
[Music]
making another bubble and I'm blowing a
stream of air there you have a planet
bubble melody says the planet bubble is
one of the hardest tricks to get right
and learning it was one of the signs she
was ready to join the family show these
tricks might be too hard for most people
but melody says even beginning blowers
can learn some fun ones so first I'm
going to make a bubble using just my
hands and bubble solution what you have
to do is your hand has to be soaked
first right cuz we need some bubble
solution to make bubbles then I'm just
going to make an okay sign flip my wrist
back blow a stream of air not too strong
not too soft
and then now you see the bubble is
getting smaller because there's air
that's escaping what you have to do is
close that hole and capture that air
cool this is another trick it's advanced
I'm joking no it's uh you can do this at
home your hands both your hands have to
be soaked this time you're gonna cross
your hands like this like hold your
hands together keep them tight and you
see all those little layers of bubbles
in between then from a distance not too
close you make sure you have your bubble
walls the films in between your fingers
you can make a whole bunch of bubbles
using just your hands what I do like
about bubbles that I think is great it
is a language that everybody understands
no matter what country we do it people
are always happy people love it you know
it's just something that is so universal
this works everywhere because it's just
something that brings like a happy vibe
a happy energy
you